JUN OKUMURA: OK so let's
start, and hi, everyone.
Thank you for joining
us today, and I'm
so excited to be
here with you today.
We're from DeNA, which is
one of the largest game
publisher in Japan,
and today we are
going to share our AI
implementation on gaming.
So far, we have released
two AI applications,
and we're going to talk
about the motivation
and the implementation, and
the outcomes of these projects.
My name is Jun Ernesto, and
I'm leading this project.
Also, let me
introduce Ikki Tanaka.
He's a data scientist,
and built our AI models.
In this part, both
of us will present.
So to be honest, this
work has been accomplished
by four machine learning
engineers, and lots
of collaborators
from gaming team.
Each of us have own
area of expertise,
and I really love this team.
So let's start.
I think most of you are
not so familiar with DeNA.
Our company is one of
the largest internet
company in Japan.
Although we have various
business domains, such as game,
automotive, and life science,
and sports, most of the revenue
comes from games.
Actually, we are providing
dozens of in-house game titles,
and other publishers' titles.
And maybe some of
you may know that we
have an alliance with Nintendo.
For example, our company is in
charge of the back-end system
of Super Mario Run.
So this is for UL.
So in the sessions,
I will talk--
I will focus on the house game
title, "Gyakuten Othellonia."
So first, I'd like to talk
about the problem we had,
and how we challenged
to solve these issues.
So this game,
"Gyakuten Othellonia,"
is a strategy app game.
The player's action is based on
the board game called Othello
or Reversi, and the player
put black and white pieces
alternatively.
And what is unique
about this game
here is that each piece
has its own skills, which
are strategic components
to the battle.
Actually, when you
start playing the game,
there are varieties
of play styles,
and the interest exploration
is required to master the game.
So this title was
released three years ago,
and fortunately,
it's still growing.
We have more than 24
million downloads so far,
and the service region
is expanding gradually.
Of course, I hope in the future,
we can release it in the US
as well.
So in Othellonia,
there's the concept
of decks and characters.
So before starting
the battle, player
constructs deck,
which is composed
of 16 characters among
more than 3,000 options,
and each character
have its own skills,
and the players have to choose
consistent characters according
to their play styles.
As you can imagine, the number
of the combination is extreme,
and it's very hard
for beginners to learn
how to build optimal decks.
Another issue here is that
building an optimal deck
requires to learn effective
strategies through the process
of trial and error.
So let me explain why
this is a problem.
So generally speaking,
if the game is complex,
a game has complex features,
which can distract players
from continuing the
game, the churn rate
increases and impacts the
future revenue, right?
And for example,
there is an estimation
that just a few points decrease
in the 30-day churn rate
can increase the revenue by
20% to 30% in the future.
So back to Othellonia--
we actually
have a high churn rate,
so we have trouble here.
And this is partly because
the game is complex, and lacks
sufficient on-boarding
support, and therefore it's
hard for beginners to
construct an optimal deck.
So also, there is
a problem that they
don't have a good
place for practice
in order to improve
their play skills.
For instance, we only have two
battle options for beginners.
One is NPC battle, which they
battle against a very, very
weak opponent; and the
other is a PvP battle,
in which they are frequently
matched against very
skilled or experienced players.
So we need a team opponent
whose play level is similar
to the beginner's.
So here's our approach.
To support beginners, we
have provided two functions.
The first one is the deck
recommendation system,
which selects appropriate
characters from players' piece
box--
and we are using
association analysis
to provide a better
recommendation.
The second one is the battle AI,
which we call Othellonia Dojo.
And in these functions,
we have developed
AI that can play at any levels.
Our deep neural network
is used for this AI.
Later, Ikki will explain
how these techniques
are used in our cases.
OK, so by the way, from the
machine learning perspective,
we need to provide--
prepare data to build such AIs.
We're correcting various
kinds of in-game data,
since the early
days of the game,
such as deck logs
and battle logs,
so we had a good amount of data
when we started this project.
And in our cases,
we used the data
for the last nine
months, which contains
billions of log entries.
Then we filtered the
data by player skills,
and augmented the original
data in the battle AI cases.
The image on the right
side is an example
of battle logs, which
is formatted in JSON,
and describes entire
state and action
information of the battle.
And the bottom diagram
shows rough data pipelines,
and BigQuery did a very good job
at this pre-processing phase.
For instance, it can handle
even terabytes order of data
very fast, and we could
reduce the processing time
drastically.
BQ could handle our data
in a few minutes and--
well, compared with on-prem
Hadoop clusters that took,
like, an hour.
So yeah, we are very,
very happy here.
And we also love that BQ is easy
to corroborate with another GCP
services.
And here I want to stress that
the aria has been successfully
built by sufficient amount of
data and a reliable pipeline.
So let's see how each of
these use cases works.
This is a rough overview of
the deck recommendation system.
So we first exploit
our pre-processed deck
logs to extract
information about how
each characters are
associated, which
we call association rules.
With this analysis, we
can score the strengths
of the relationship across
all the pair of characters.
If there is a request
from the player,
the recommendation
server response--
I mean, the received set of
characters in the player space
box, and it fills
all the 16 characters
according to the score
of association rules.
This function is very
flexible, and the player
can specify a deck archetype
and deck cost, and also
the favorite characters to
be included in the deck.
Regarding KPIs, we are
monitoring several metrics.
For instance, we're
watching how many players
have used this
recommendation system,
and whether the recommended
deck has been accepted,
or whether the take contributed
to the players in terms
of win rate at battles.
As for the Dojo, a player
can battle against AI
with various archetypes
and strengths.
So here, we train a
deep neural network
from pre-processed battle logs.
The client sent
current game status,
and the battle
API server returns
the inference of neural networks
at every turn of the battle.
And as for the metrics,
we're monitoring
how frequently the Dojo
is used for beginners,
and whether the strength of
AI was sufficient in terms
of win rate.
So these two AIs have
already been released,
and we are observing
possible KPIs.
And before showing
the results, I
want to pass the talk
to Ikki, and he'll
talk about the technical
details, and some tips
for building AI.
IKKI TANAKA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Ikki, and a data
scientist at DeNA.
So I'm one of the
developers that
created our gaming system by
using machine learning and data
science.
So today, I will talk of the
technical details of our use
cases with GCP.
So now let's look at the
story of the technical part.
First, I'd like to start off
by the deck recommendation.
This is the outline of the
deck recommender algorithm.
Firstly, the algorithm
receives some inputs
from a player, such as a
deck archetype, the cost,
the possessed characters,
and the character
the player wants to use.
Next, the algorithm
selects a leader
by using the result
of association
analysis and statistical data.
In this algorithm, the leader
character is chosen first,
and the next characters are
selected based on the leader.
The way associated
characters are simply
selected based on the result
of association analysis.
If the deck is not
full of 16 characters,
another character is selected--
as a best character.
After repeating this
procedure several times,
the recommended deck is
proposed to the player.
If the game is different,
the way of fine tuning
is also different.
In our game "Gyakuten
Othellonia,"
for example, we made additional
rules to decide a leader,
and we ignored the
characters whose skill will
be never activated in the deck.
I'd like to give a
brief explanation
about how to extract
the relationships
between characters.
In our recommendation, we are
using the association analysis.
The association analysis is a
rules-based machine-learning
method for discovering
meaningful relations
between content
in large data set.
This method can perform
a high speed calculation
to extract the many rules,
and the extracted relations
are easy to understand and
useful in various settings.
So our relations are
evaluated with some metrics,
like the strength
of the connections
and the frequency of
the rules and patterns.
Our recommendation with a deck
by selecting the characters
sequentially is stronger
relationships one to another.
This method can handle the
various kinds of data easily,
so this technique is applicable
to many games and other fields.
Next, I will talk of the system.
So we build our applications,
like the deck recommendation
and the divining
AI bot with GCP.
So why did we choose GCP for
our machine learning systems?
There are two main reasons.
The first line is that GCP has
powerful and flexible tools
for machine learning
and data science.
In the data analysis, we often
try to investigate the data,
visualize it, and create
the prototype models.
The GCP services for
big data analysis
make it possible for
us, such as BigQuery,
acquire data lab, and
Google Compute Engine.
And cloud storage provides
scalable and faster storage
service for large
data, and it helps
us to manage big data and a
lot of machine learning models.
About Cloud ML Engine, we
can deploy the AI models
to Cloud Machine Learning
Engine easily and quickly,
and it also provides
user-friendly APIs.
Additionally, these people
buy many services to perform
machine learning efficiently.
For example, we are
trying to use a GK control
service and a Cloud
ML Engine training
with customer functions
for scalable [INAUDIBLE]
distributed
[INAUDIBLE] trainings.
The second one is that GCP
has scalable and robust
infrastructure services.
We can run the
applications easily
by using Google App Engine with
several programming languages,
like Python and Go languages.
And we can check many metrics
through Stackdriver, logging,
and others.
I'd like to emphasize that
auto scaling of the Google App
Engine is a very good service
because the new instances are
increased or stopped
in response to traffic,
and the requests are distributed
to the instances automatically.
These GCP services are easy to
integrate into the same system.
Moreover, although I don't
touch on the product details,
Google Cloud brings many
advantages to our business,
like a security
correlation and openness.
For these many reasons,
we are choosing
GCP for our ML systems.
Next, I'll show the system
architecture of the deck
recommendation with GCP.
The deck logs are saved
in BigQuery, which
are used to extract the rules.
We set the [INAUDIBLE] to
perform the batch processing
of the association analysis
in Google Compute Engine,
and in order to catch up the
trained decks with the latest
characters, we are performing
batch processing every day.
Then cloud functions
pre-processes the result
of association analysis
and updates the data
for production
environment in GCS.
Cloud function checks if the
data is uploaded correctly,
for example, if the data
size is too small or large.
Then we are using
Google Engine Python
3.7 for our
recommendation API server.
The server receives a
request from the client,
then builds a deck
using analyzer data,
and finally, it returns a
recommended deck to the player.
One of the notable point
is that [INAUDIBLE]
Python 3.7 was
generally available
at the end of last year,
so we could use it just
at the right time.
As a result of
upgrade to Python 3.7,
we didn't need to change
our code that we had already
developed in Python 3.
So far, I've explained the
algorithm and the system
with deck recommendation.
Let's move on to the next
topic, deep learning AI bot.
It's called Othellonia Dojo.
Dojo means a training room
to improve playing skills.
This is an overview of the
training in deep learning AI
bot.
Deep learning was
suitable for our case
to learn many complicated
features, such as the state
of decks, boards,
and hands, status,
and the combination
of the features.
The deep learning AI bot
receives a state of battle
from the client.
The information
battle is converted
to the numerical
features, which are used
as inputs of the deep learning.
Here, we created
model 5000 features.
The network learns the
actions of top-tier players
as binary classification.
Finally, the deep learning
model outputs the values
of each action that will be
used to decide the next action.
We used more than 10 million
battle records in the training.
In our training, we are
using the battle records
of highly skilled
players, but we
need to create the AI
with appropriate skills
for beginners.
In order to divide the strengths
of AI into multiple levels,
we are processing the
inference results.
Specifically, we select the
highest evaluation value
when we want to
make a strong AI,
and if we want to weaken
the strength of AI,
we select the second or third
value with the probability.
Technically, the
probability is calculated
by [INAUDIBLE] function,
which transforms
the values into [INAUDIBLE]
property distribution.
After tuning the probabilities,
we made five levels of AI.
In the latter part, we will
show the remarkable results
of the winning rates
against the actual players.
Next, I will show
the system of AI bot.
First of all, I'll talk
about the training phase.
A large number of
battle records in PvP
is stored in cloud
storage through BigQuery.
The training process consists
of the pre-processing
of the features
and model training,
which are running in
Google Compute Engine.
At the pre-processing,
the features
are generated on demand
by emulating the game.
In our case, we created
the custom function
of data generator that
creates the features
during the training.
After the training,
the trained AI model
is saved in cloud storage
to deploy onto the Cloud ML
engine.
Regarding the continuous
integration and delivery
of machine learning--
it's so-called CI/CD-- we are
testing the training modules
to check the dependencies
and the features
automatically by using the unit
test and the evaluation test.
Also, it is important to deploy
the AI model automatically
in short cycles with
high reliability
when releasing new models.
We are currently
trying to simplify
the complicated process from
training to deployment by using
CI/CD the tools for executing
it more quickly and easy.
I think we can
leverage the cloud
to build the continuous
delivery service of GCP
to accomplish better CI/CD.
I'll move on to the
inference phase.
Please take a look
at the communication
between the client and
the inference API server
on the left of the slide.
The battle record is a
[INAUDIBLE] design [INAUDIBLE]
API server from the client who
is playing against an AI bot.
The inference API server
reproduces a battle
from the record, then
extracts the features,
and it sends the features
to the Online Prediction
API of the Cloud ML Engine.
Online Prediction
of Cloud ML Engine
is very useful because
it is optimized
to run the AI model with
low latency in real time.
Cloud ML engine uses
a trained AI model
stored in cloud
storage, and returns
the values of each action.
The values are sent
back to the client,
and the client moves
towards the battle step
by selecting the best action
according to the values.
That's the overall communication
between the client and server.
[INAUDIBLE] engine
and Cloud ML Engine
can auto scale in
response to the traffic.
That's a very good function.
By taking the benefit
of the autoscaling,
we can manage a large
amount of requests.
Lastly, I'll touch on
the technical topic--
the testing of the systems.
So why should we
test the systems?
I mentioned in the last
slide the Cloud ML engine
can autoscale.
That's good-- yes,
that's true, but we
didn't have enough knowledge
about how much load
the system can withstand.
In the mobile game,
generally the load
tends to increase at the
moment a new event opens.
The figure on the
slide shows the example
of the estimated requests per
second in a realistic event.
This is a trial calculation
that the request per second will
increased to several
hundreds in 10 minutes.
We have to check in
advance if is a system
can withstand like this load.
As a point-- we cannot predict
the action of AI as batch
processing at regular intervals.
Our system has to respond to
the request in real time--
that is, where the should put
the character in the next turn.
To achieve this, we chose
the online prediction
of the Cloud ML Engine.
We have checked if the
Cloud ML Engine can satisfy
our requirements by
performing a lot of testings
in advance of the release.
In our case, the
testing was performed
in the setting of the
request to increase linearly
and to reach a maximum
1000 request per second.
We found that the Cloud ML
engine can scale quickly
in response to the requests,
and the average latency
of the prediction is
less than one second.
However, there were
[INAUDIBLE] that
took a longer time than
usual, since this might not
be possible to return all the
request to the player quickly,
so we needed to
resolve this condition.
Our team and the
Cloud ML Engine team
cooperated to investigate
the bottlenecks.
Then we found that the
timeout had happened
when the new instances
warmed up in the process
of the autoscaling
due to our heavy load.
It was challenging to handle a
large number of requests which
consist of many features
at the same time
with online prediction.
But if we can
resolve this problem
by building an efficient
back end system,
we don't have to warm up
the system beforehand,
and the system will
be more robust.
So our team took the time
to deal with this problem.
Let's take a look at how we
tackle to remove the errors.
When the error returns
within the time,
we can simply throw it
back again to the API.
But in the case of timeout,
the system cannot send it back
again because a timeout
error is not returned.
Therefore when the inference
API server does not
receive the response
within five seconds,
the request is sent
back to the API
again, because something bad
has happened in the inference.
Also, if the destination of the
request is the same endpoint,
it will further increase
the load on the server.
As a result, we set
another backup endpoint
to receive the request
that fails to be
operated in the main endpoint.
That is the second request sent
to the backup endpoint, which
is prepared independently
from the main endpoint.
This is a result of
a lot of testings
with a backup endpoint.
The figure shows
the total error rate
of several settings-- no backup,
backup with 10 minimum nodes,
and the backup with
20 minimum nodes.
In the case without backup
endpoint, on the left,
about 1.3% of errors remained.
In the middle setting of the
backup with 10 minimum nodes,
although small errors
still remained,
the backup can deal with
mostly the main point errors.
We found that the reason
of this small error
was because the number of
backup instances was small,
so the timeout
had still happened
as a warmup of the autoscaling
in the backup environment.
The rightmost case is
a fine tuned setting,
where the number
of backup instances
were set to 20 for covering
the main endpoint errors
sufficiently.
In this case, we could
handle all the requests
without errors.
In this way, DeNA and
the Cloud ML Engine team
got over the challenge high and
spiky traffic and the latest
limit without errors.
After deployment
in this setting,
the system has been stable
in handling many requests.
Let me show you one more thing--
it's a useful service to
monitor the system performances.
We can check the
server performances
through Stackdriver, which
provides error reporting, auto
notification, logging, trace
of latency, and many others.
Stackdriver dashboard especially
provides a visualization too
that is easy to add a
chart and customize it.
We are monitoring the
many metrics according
to our needs in one place.
For example, the
number of requests,
API latencies, and
CPU and memory usage,
and the number of learning
instances in real time.
Additionally, you can
change the time window
to focus on and check
the percent of values.
We are using 99 percentile
values for anomaly detection
in the system.
So far, I have explained the
technical details of our AI
with GCP.
The system with GCP can
be constructed flexibly
to cope with various problems
in gaming and other fields.
Now I'd like to hand over to Jun
for the KPI result of our use
cases in the future.
Thanks.
JUN OKUMURA: OK.
So this is our result part.
So as Ikki mentions, we needed
a scalable and robust system
to successfully reduce our AIs.
So in this final
part, I would like
to share what happened
after the release.
So first, for the
deck recommendation,
here is a chart which shows
the number of beginners
who use deck recommendations.
There were constant
usage after the release,
but this function was not
well known at this time.
But the station has
been changed after we
started an in-game
event to promote
players to build new decks.
So the deck
recommendation system
has been recognized more,
and even after the event
has finished, many players,
and mostly beginners,
are still using these
function frequently.
So second, I will [INAUDIBLE]
that the recommended deck
push the win rates of
the beginners by about 5%
compared to deck created
without that recommendation.
So since our focus was
to support beginners,
we are very satisfied
with these results.
Also, I'd like to mention
that this function has
good adoption, even
from top tier players.
This was a sort of
byproduct, but we
are observing that
heavy players usually
update their deck frequently,
and this recommendation system
mitigates the course of
piecing deck from scratch.
They use recommendation
as a first suggestion,
and then customize
the deck as they want.
So let's see the
system matrix as well.
After the release, we
have a stable latency
of 20 millisecond, which is
fast enough for our cases,
and we're surprised by the
result, because recommend
has shown our rhythm
is very complex,
and we haven't expected
such a low latency.
So the autoscaling
does a good job,
and we haven't had any
system trouble so far.
So briefly, we will explain
about the evaluation
of the deep learning AI bot.
After the release,
we are observing
that our AI bot has good
enough win rate as a practice
partner for beginners.
So this chart shows the win
rates of AI against players.
The horizontal axis denotes
the player's skill levels,
and the vertical axis
is the win rate of AI.
So in the Dojo, we provide
five different AI levels,
and the strongest one can
even beat top-tier players
with a win rate of 50%.
So we think that our
AI is strong enough
for beginner support.
So from beginner's perspective,
win rates of AI ranges
from about 20% to 8%, which
means that the player can
choose any--
I mean appropriate--
levels of AI
according to their
skills or preferences.
So therefore, this AI works
as a sort of a good mentor.
Although this was
released last month,
and we don't have enough data
to evaluate the business impact,
those rates are used
by beginners very well,
and we hope that these can lead
to a good KPI in the future.
And as for the system
metrics, the inference
of this Cloud Machine Learning
Engine is about 200 to 300
millisecond, and very stable.
Even for the entire
system, the response time
is about a second, which is
enough fast for our case.
And backup endpoint
is working well,
and we don't have
system trouble so far.
So at the end of my
talk, I'll show items
which worked in our cases.
So first, to train the AI that
play the game like a human,
we need the battle logs that
completely reproduce battle
status and actions.
So if you have some random
effects in the game,
make sure that the random
seeds are stored in the logs.
So secondly, for the
evolution of our AI,
we needed to run
thousands of battles
to get performance statistics,
so a [INAUDIBLE] simulator
helps us a lot in this context.
And, well, if you want to try
to use reinforcement learning
techniques, you also need to--
a very, very fast simulator,
because the number
of the battle that our
[INAUDIBLE] goes through really
matters.
And the third, we
also want to stress
that AI scalable
and robust system
is critical for implementing
AI in real services.
We think that GCP in particular,
[INAUDIBLE] Machine Learning
Engine, and GAE were
a good choice for us.
And as for the CI/CD, we have
to think about how frequently,
or by which trigger, the
AI model should be updated.
Because the game environment
changes frequently,
we need to keep--
adding features and retraining
the models after [INAUDIBLE]..
So this operation is
very heavy, and we
have to think about the CI/CD,
I mean before the release,
in particular in the
AI modeling phase.
The final item is not
technical, but a critical.
Generally speaking, we don't
know how well AI will perform,
and how big the
business impact will
be before starting a project.
So in such an uncertain case--
situation-- the communication
and controlling the expectation
is very, very important.
Although we are machine
learning engineers,
we try to understand the
game and the business issues
correctly, and I think
that this was a key factor
of the success of this project.
So that's all from
me, and I'd like
to pass the summary to Henry.
Thanks.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
HENRY TAPPEN: Hi, everybody.
I'm Henry Tappen--
I'm a product manager on
the AI platform team working
on what was formerly known
as the Cloud Machine Learning
Engine, but we've just
rebranded to be the AI Platform.
This was a really
exciting thing,
so we've been working
with the DeNA folks
for a while for this one,
mostly being inspired
by the very elegant way that
they took a number of machine
learning techniques and
built an awesome experience
for their beginner gamers.
Now when we saw
this, we notice there
was a lot of different
things that they
had to use a lot of different
pieces of technology
between App Engine, Compute
Engine, the Cloud Machine
Learning Engine, and
so on and so forth.
So the challenge
to us at Google is,
how could we make it
even easier for teams
like DeNA, or other
gaming companies,
to get started even
faster producing
these kinds of innovative,
but also very accessible,
gaming experiences
for it using things
like machine learning and AI?
So we've been working
on a number of features
to make the process of
getting started that much
easier and that much simpler.
So one of the ones
that we noticed
was starting to think
more about machine
learning beyond just
TensorFlow, scikit, and XGBoost.
So Cloud Machine
Learning Engine was
one of the first
cloud-based platforms
that enabled you to train a
TensorFlow model in the cloud.
Since then, in the
last few years,
we've added support
for other libraries,
like scikit-learn and XGBoost.
But especially,
seeing what was done
with association rules and
other data mining techniques,
we realized that the world--
and the world and the
problems are much bigger
than that, which is easy to
do inside of these frameworks.
And so we've been
working on introducing
support for custom containers
into our training component.
This is now available
in a public beta--
we expect to go to full release,
probably in this quarter,
but certainly inside of 2019.
Where with custom containers,
you can take any code,
any framework that you can stick
inside of a Docker container,
and then push it to the
Cloud Machine Learning
Engine in the same
way that you would
use TensorFlow models
or scikit or XGBoost
or any other kinds
of training scripts.
So this gives you access to,
not only traditional machine
learning frameworks like
TensorFlow, PyTorch, Cafe, et
cetera, but also to
run any other software
that you might need.
So if you've written
some C++, some Java code,
some different Python routines,
even our code for solving
certain parts of your analysis
or production of models,
you can now go ahead and easily
train them on the Cloud Machine
Learning Engine.
Additionally, it's
not shown on here,
but we've also been
thinking more about
how we get easier pipelines for
solving some of these things.
So earlier-- late last year, we
released into the open source
a system called Kubeflow
Pipelines, which
is a composition
and an orchestration
engine for running machine
learning-focused workloads.
On Kubeflow Pipelines, you can
start up a Kubernetes cluster
on GKE, or on your own
premises, et cetera;
specify a simple workflow that
says all the different steps
you'd like to do on
the way, including
training jobs on the Cloud
Machine Learning Engine;
and then the Kubeflow
Pipeline system
will take care of doing
all the steps necessary,
making sure that it
runs, runs effectively.
So this could be a
great way for tackling
bigger parts of your
machine learning workflow
besides just the actual training
part at the very end of it.
So the second thing that
we really were inspired by
and have been working on is--
I think Jun-san pointed out
very, very well that when--
and Ikki as well-- that when
predictions come back from--
the machine learning framework
or as you're putting data
into the systems, you often
need to do other transformations
to make it compatible
for the game.
So coming back to the
example of the AI,
it wasn't enough to just
get a particular score back
from the model, but they
also needed to select,
based on the player's skill
level, a random choice
of a different option in it.
Now this could be
really hard, and you
might have to set up different
servers for post-processing
or pre-processing the
data before you send it
to the Machine Learning Engine.
So to make this simpler,
we have available as
of today in beta the
ability to run any Python
code on the Cloud Machine
Learning Engine prediction
service before or after
you make any predictions.
So if you need to
reshape some data,
maybe take a different result,
convert from a score back
into label, so on and
so forth, it's now just
as simple as giving
us a Python class,
and you've got whatever you need
to make happen along the way.
This, incidentally,
also gives you
some more flexibility as well.
We allow you to install
any Python packages
on the inference server
as well, and then
do whatever you'd like
with inside those packages.
So you have many more
options for running jobs
on side of our machine
learning systems.
And then finally, the
other big advancement
that we've seen that was I think
especially relevant for gaming,
and one thing that
was inspired by DeNA,
is giving better flexibility
and better capacity for it.
So you know, it's
really great to see
heavy usage of our
systems, and we
want to make sure
that we're giving you
exactly the capabilities
that you need,
that you're able to run
your jobs bulletproof,
even for when you
have high demand,
burst-y instances for it.
So today, in the
Machine Learning Engine
on the prediction side,
you're able to choose
either a four-core or
a dual-core machine
with a choice of RAM in there.
We're expanding this range of
options to be virtually any
machine type that's supported on
Cloud Machine Learning Engine,
or-- we're sorry, that's for
support on the Google Compute
Engine--
and including into the support
for accelerators like GPUs.
So that way, if you've got a job
that is very intense, or very
burst-y, or you want to maintain
a certain level of latency,
you're now able to select
many more machine types
and much more power
to those ones,
especially those we're looking
for really complex models,
like reinforcement
learning, where you're
trying to beat the
next StarCraft AI,
this might be a
great option for you.
So let's kind of sum
up with these things.
This was a chance
for us to see that AI
can be used for much more than
recognizing images or speech
or something, but
we can actually
use machine learning AI to
create compelling gaming
experiences.
Both to challenge
our players, for when
we want to give
them a smarter AI,
but also to assist them so
that beginners have an even
playing field with
those who have
been on it for a long time.
And the result of these
kinds of experiences
can result in better engagement
and revenue for your game.
And then finally, to note
that Google Cloud is here
to help-- we're very interested
in the gaming segment,
we're very interested
in machine learning.
So anything that we can do
to help you achieve success
in your gaming,
we're happy to do it.